[Music]
welcome to CBS this morning while you
were sleeping government dysfunction was
on full display in Washington a short
time ago the House approved a compromise
funding bill and sent it to the
President to sign to end the second
government shutdown in just three weeks
the Senate voted for the measure after a
midnight deadline because of a long
protest by Republican Senator Rand Paul
he blasted members of his own party for
abandoning their view of government
spending and fiscal responsibility
it's a litmus test of hypocrisy if they
were against trillion dollar deficits
for President Obama why is it okay to be
a Republican deficit of a trillion
dollars I think there's no escaping the
hypocrisy of that Nancy Cordes is on
Capitol Hill with the last-minute push
to get the government open on time Nancy
good morning good morning well they're
trying to get this bill to the president
as quickly as possible because most
federal employees frankly did not go to
bed last night expecting that their
government would shut down and so this
really was a scramble as usual Congress
left this deal to the last minute
leaving very little margin for error and
then error appeared in the form of
Kentucky Republican Rand Paul who
decided to take a stand on the cost of
the deal which lifts spending caps on
both domestic and defense outlays it
also includes a ninety billion dollar
outlay for disaster relief plus a
one-year elimination of the debt ceiling
so the total price tag here about three
hundred billion dollars and annual
budget deficits that could exceed a
trillion dollars now Rand Paul is not
the only Republican who has argued that
their party is now going to be running
up the same deficits for which they
criticized President Obama the rest just
weren't willing to court a government
shutdown over it and so once his time
ran out overnight this plan actually
passed by wide margins in the House and
the Senate
this government overnight shutdown was
so unexpected that most federal
administrators didn't have any time to
plan for it some overnight employees
were sent home the rest are being told
to check with their federal agency
before they come in this morning Nancy
thanks